hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome doubt last - now I know like
many of you out there I have been
waiting for this game for a long long
time and I am so so ready to get into
this and I'm only gonna play it on
normal because I know I'm gonna die
already so I might as well just get fits
just make it a little bit easier on me
and oh boy
intense violence core graphic sexual
content and strong language
please enjoy Oh for your fellow
masochist out there there's going to be
a fun ride Lin Lang Ehrman is an
investigative journalist seeking the
answers behind a pregnant woman murdered
under impossible circumstances in rural
Arizona you are Blake Langerman her
husband assistant and cameraman record
everything neither of you are fighters
to navigate the horrors waiting for you
in the desert your only choices are to
run hide or die oh my land laid waste
but my okay never mind then I don't know
it's dark me too
I don't know I'm here maybe you could
tell me a little bit of that
[Music]
Jesus Blake are you really sleeping I'm
awake you should have slept last night I
had to get that hospital footage
organized what's in your sleep
Jessica I think you know what Jessica oh
no I mean I was dreaming about Jessica
we were kids she had to have spent at
least a decade downstream from some
pretty heavy industry about the time we
should record an intro what we're up
here production yeah sure okay good
thing I'm a cameraman yes oh crap well
sorry mcLeese it's fine okay we're good
we're good
I got it I got these trees have a soup I
have a super day Indian Reservation in
central Arizona they search the origins
I don't think you should say murdered we
don't know that so what the police
report says we played us before the
doctor interviews if this falls on the
first 30 we need to get the word murder
in there
we should probably measure the fetus to
it how I just made you big fetus that's
good idea okay Joe weeks ago I was
wandering
but pregnant and alone on a barren
stretch highway
Oh righty then okay great here we in the
middle of the game holy [ __ ] that's out
where I don't know where we are I don't
know why we're here I thought I was
crashing and dying hey how are you doing
you good I'm good if you're good I'm
good
oh what a lovely school Oh delightful is
this my - Jessica oh is that the same
Jessica we were talking about are these
my dreams with which disturbed me hi oh
hi principal come back I need to learn
my education is important okay Oh God
alright then so for this just feels like
it accelerated or no this feels like a
slowed down version of the demo because
in my imagination I thought the demo was
completely unrelated to the main game of
it why is there a choir following me
down this hallway
oh that's necessary I mean last sound
last I had the Haunted tuba behind me
maybe you could just go maybe you know
[ __ ] off please I need to concentrate on
my education
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I can tell by the river of blood out my
bones oh oh my impinged ligaments dude
Oh Howie oh boy
so is that Jessica was that Linda or
Laura or Lana Minh
Oh tap oh okay
at least my camera made it that's good
that's good that's normal
okay here we go everyone's dead
Lin I know oh boy
pressing my dad nothing matters but Lin
oh okay that's a little let's see what I
did here huh they got my zooms in there
I can't believe it they recorded all of
that that's awesome oh that's so cool
okay so I got to find Lin how do I do
that do I just jump like a mouse oh not
supposed to jump I'm sorry I just
started I have already dead this way
ah the non stupid way all right here we
go then we okay alrighty then press
space while moving forward alright Sam
is in the last one a good bit of
mobility whoo oh [ __ ] all right
whoa razor camera recording will start
him automatically oh yes oh my god oh my
god is that fire yeah that's not good
Jesus Jesus is once yeah please follow
the sound of my voice Lynn Lynn oh boy
well I have a funny feeling gue oh no oh
no no it's classic outlast the
night-vision perfect I love it oh I love
it
I've been waiting so long Oh God Oh God
for [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god yeah no joke
that didn't happen in the crash alrighty
then
okay here we go into the darkness oh boy
I can't wait to find out what was the
cause of that guy's immediate death oh I
forgot about the looking over shoulder
mechanic oh I love so much of it oh I
love every bit of it
oh it's so good excuse me I slip and
slide my way down here what the town
what the town it was from anything
that's windmill he's so suspicious okay
never mind that I guess I'm not gonna be
recording that
got a giddy seda church-tower
oh my god oh my god got it nailed it I'm
the best
I can't move for some reason I'm just
gonna get God there alrighty then
swing swing my arms down here oh this is
definitely from the demo I'm lost and
hurt
womp womp womp hello anybody there
anybody at all ok
alright then I don't recall anybody
opening this before anyway anybody in
there
hello hello ok nice corn I'm gonna be on
my way now
ah that's so cool oh oh I'm running very
fast ok Oh
I'm not gonna open slowly oh geez
it is so dark oh I remember you okay so
you can stop any time now I remember
fine man hey man you okay man oh yeah no
joke you might want to record this or
something nah all right good enough beer
sweet Ellie I can't bear what we've done
nor being apart from our little ones so
I'm going over and hoping you forgive me
for leaving you behind and God forgives
me of this last trespass I know that
they had to be offered up but I'm all
torn up inside and can't live no more
hopefully the end will come soon and we
can be together again
unless God burns me forever for this sin
until then I hope you find what women's
comfort you need in the arms of poppin
off yours forever oh good old poppin off
gonna give all the all the villagers
with that woman's comfort oh I'm sure
about that oh why why is that you poppin
off so that's what all the Bible's said
it was like the book of not oh hi are
you all right fine then goodbye so this
is all part of the demo so never mind
looks no doorknob on that one
hold peak I need to peek who needs to
peek honest slow hey how's it goin there
buddy
how are you doing you look you look
perturbed it's something you sure you're
okay you all right buddy all right okay
oh it's just craps down there yeah you
still okay never mind he's gone all
right
yeah gross all right away I go oh [ __ ]
off with you Oh
Jesus what is with all this Oh
Zeca dole poppin off hello hello hello
okay alright then oh well okay again I
need to reiterate stop screaming there
is no need to scream this early in the
goddamn game yes oh that's [ __ ] up
Oh everything else I saw thus far was
not [ __ ] up at this one this [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] up
that little guy he's [ __ ] up oh I know
reload
alright here we go to open windows press
this fine you're gonna be like that
you're gonna get me with scares I
already done been scared by [ __ ] you
alright some doors have dead bolts
alright okay off we go oh I remember you
I remember all of this
alright let's go I think we're about to
go through the cavern of babies which
knows is a lovely blaze
God Satan something God do you know if
that means birdie boo all right I'm
gonna keep going because I need more bad
a reason cuz I don't want to run out of
batteries in this horrifying place all
right what do we got here
midwife's lament wait don't do that are
you doing how do I take a picture did I
already the babe is coming ready the
knife the baby's coming Knights midwife
mother did the enemy stained with in
God's creation saved with sin
hallelujah stay the storm no longer must
we wait for come the dawn neom and to be
born to die in temple gate the babies
growing her belly swells the babies
growing sent from Hell Ezekiel waits a
sharpening his blade got to gather at
the gate and we kneel and pray would
sing this Oh God
[Music]
I already been here I already know what
happens next
yeah alright then I've already done this
I know I know it's bad so come on come
at me bro come at me come at me I know
it's kind of change because in the last
one it was sort of some sort of mania
flipping in and out from between reality
and distortion and and it seems like
this one is a continuous chain of
reality and I don't like that music
that's a bit more ominous than I would
like right now you just tone it down a
few decibels that'd be great
and the book of the who and the lamb
slain please tell me I'm not them Lynn
hello hello hi hi oh you're not good oh
you're not good you're gonna kill me dad
aren't you oh oh oh oh oh you're the one
that chopped off my nether regions
before okay here we go
Jimmy boo ba [ __ ] me too boo I'm gonna
go in here whoo screw you did I lock
anything did pick up bandits that's good
can I open this no that's jammed up okay
he thinks I need to hurry a bit but
there's a battery okay let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go go
go go go go go go is it behind me no
thank goodness
okay Go Go Go Go Go can't open there Oh
God can I crawl under this no I cannot
Oh God no [ __ ] me bye oh [ __ ] me Jesus
Christ
Oh God hi no please
why always the crotch
you see poopsie
oh I'm such a goof oh where did it drop
okay it's you again so I'm right here
how many finer isn't nothing matters but
Linda okay oh I see pocket for batteries
pocket for that but I don't need to
worry about that right now yeah ladies
in captivity do you know where the drugs
are going all the batteries laughs oh
yeah a fantasy okay so I gotta find
another way to go around this place that
record you at least before you murder me
so good yeah where you at lady lady lady
with the big ol pickaxe where you be
hello
where's he go
but you go where did she go
okay I still need to get this battery
you pick up battery okay don't jump in
front of a window enjoy just yet I think
death still awaits ye okay so this ah
there's a lock here so how do i how do I
get in here and where did she go okay
that's what I was supposed to do I
didn't see that oh [ __ ]
what do i do okay get up that get up
okay you can't get me up here I'm rubber
you're glue go screw yourself and your
people have made war in the fields and
my son Eretz Israel
my landlady wastes but my seed firmly
set against Babylon in the arena Syrian
and against Rome but fall into the
[ __ ] and failed in the Crusades in
betrayed in the time of the publican
Pharisees as it was written by Baruch
Ben Neriah in the words of the weeping
Jeremiah the prophets prophesy falsely
in the priests bear rule the lucre and
shame my people love to have it so be
thou instructed Oh Ezekiel as my son
depart from thee let not thy face be
uncircumcised in that Jeremiah thou must
now weep not tears thou must weave is
even blood oh boy and Sullivan oft
inscribed his name as Ezekiel upon
eternities banner with iron blade he
scratched the word ID on the globe of
his eye and it was slit and bled in his
faces washed with tears and blood thus
saith the true Lord now may I show you
the truth for you have cutline face and
covenant to me and the Lord saith you
have not cut away thine eye but the
scale you took for an eye and now you
may see
okay I don't know what any of that means
but I read it so I'm assuming I'm curse
now but that's what naath did apparently
so not big papanov supposedly believes
him to be a prophet of God my glasses
lately is this you can't see without my
glasses man before the end of this my
glasses are gonna break oh no I don't
want God I mean not right now anyway
okay okay all right bye
goodbye okay oh boy boy we got some
interesting characters in this in this
universe don't we oh yeah okay I'm
assuming I just go out and Gander this
way then yeah so yeah okay your camera
is equipped with a microphone here
through walls and track sounds
that throne is from generation to
generation
[Applause]
okay all right then you'll take care now
I'm gonna go this way you can hide by
crawling is that like a warning is that
did I need to do this oh okay I'm gonna
go for this I I'm tired of this waiting
game
let's just let's go for this let's go
for it let's go for it hi didn't
waist-high plants what qualifies as a
waist-high plant do those mm-hmm
I'm kind of out in the open I can't just
down the open oh oh I don't like that
you got to find the enemies Pia
echolocation pretty much oh boy
okay I don't think there's anyone in
there but then again I've been wrong
before I just jumped for joy again I'm
gonna I'm just gonna hide under the bed
real quick don't need to get under there
get under there oh my god [ __ ] you dude
[ __ ] you you stupid douche okay so
apparently the microphone takes battery
- oh boy okay so I got to get by these
people okay I think now is my time oh
boy turn that off oh okay so I just
gotta wait for that guy to go by there's
someone coming up from behind that's
okay oh I'm in the shadow we can't see
me I'm in the shadow I can't see me
Oh God okay all right I'm gonna record
this apparently as I run
[Music]
woman would that be Lin Bobby Lin got
rebellious angel from the sky oh boy oh
boy
the red
I should probably open those slowly at
some point
[Music]
[Music]
their lives there's so many voices going
on I have no idea what to pay attention
to Jesus Christ
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay her child is [ __ ] you
alrighty then thank you for that can I
say very enter is there they're gonna
actually try to kill her or something
are they gonna take her cuz they say her
child is the bad one the Antichrist
which is a weird conclusion to reach I
can hide by entering the Wardrobe do I
want to do that I'm gonna open this one
slowly very slowly hello oh there's
someone in there maybe not a good idea
to open that one hmm when can I jump at
this one Lin wait for me
Lin was it really that easy Lin
oh hi Lin oh god bleah how did she just
get like that [ __ ] no we have to run
there well how did she get out they were
in their own little trance about that
well the integrand stuff and she just
gets out okay good for her I guess
are we going away from here
anywhere but here yeah good idea okay
finally a horror game where people have
some common sense
get out that's all you need to know
don't explore get out there even
investigative journalists and they're
just like I need to get out No
now done don't tell me we're actually
gonna have ourselves some sort of a
divine providence situation here
I just need oh boy this is Christ Lynn
what's happening here I think it's
Immaculate Conception I'm here we're
gonna get out I can't talk about it boy
[Music]
how about you don't do that that's the
second option okay stay back
swear to [ __ ] Christ the first person
who touches me loose dies
[ __ ] you
I lost my father baki Oh God
Oh [ __ ] sake
mother
we have
I think I'll see you again okay thank
you I appreciate that thank you thank
you for that why again why do you
express your love through punching I
feel like that's just not necessary I
feel like at this point we could be
close enough without all the punching in
my face when
please God what the [ __ ] is going on
with my vision call them heretics oh
that's not Lynn :
Oh mother I thought host Lynn I was like
oh no Lynn dead oh that's Christensen
something else heretics I think they
call them right before they die by
getting their eyes exploded into their
brains well this is a whole heck of [ __ ]
up huh
man what a first episode here either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
I am so confused there was so many
people talking all at once it's gonna
take a while just to decode that a holy
[ __ ] this is quite an opening to this
game I cannot wait to get into the meat
of this story because I'm already
confused and is quite a rush in the
beginning but thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think down in the comments below and as
always I will see you
[Music]